I like making decks that make people question
their preconceptions about deckbuilding,
and about the EDH format as a whole. And one
of my favorite examples of this is my Glissa
deck. It is a battlecruiser deck that uses
its command zone to give it a consistent,
high-quality early creature, thereby allowing the
cards in the 99 to be a pile of greedy, high-cost
nonsense. Just look at that beautiful monster
of a curve. This sort of massive-nonsense-tribal
deck is really fun for when I don’t wanna
play a deck that’s particularly challenging,
and would prefer to just indulge my battlecruiser
desires. But unfortunately, there’s a problem.
This deck plays a shitload of removal to disrupt
opposing gameplans, and this works out quite well
for the deck’s general gameplan—ramping to a
double digit land count as fast as possible and
then turning on the boss music. But this gameplan
can be a bit… contentious at times. Not so much
that I never play it, but enough so that it can’t
be my default mid-power fun deck for when I don’t
wanna think too hard—people get annoyed if I spend
too much time as the final boss. All this to say,
for the past 6 months I’ve been vaguely
looking around for a battlecruiser deck
that might be able to scratch similar itches
while being a bit less brutal to play against.
A little while back, somebody mentioned to
me the idea of running Radha, Heir to Keld as
a commander, and this got my noggin joggin’. You
know what sucks to draw in the late game? Low cost
ramp spells. Any ramp deck worth its salt needs
to coordinate the ratio of ramp to other stuff,
and also the ratio of low cost ramp to high
cost ramp. Running a lot of low-cost ramp
leads to beautiful curve-outs and buttery-smooth
early-midgames, but it also leads to running out
of cards faster and worsens the quality of later
game topdecks. I built a Goreclaw deck awhile back
that ran 16 low cost ramp spells, with the goal
to land Goreclaw turn 2 or 3 and then vomit out
a massive amount of power and toughness on turns
4-5. The deck did a great job of accomplishing
exactly that task, but it pretty much either won
quickly or ran out of steam after eating a couple
removal spells or a board wipe. Running a lot of
draw is the best way to avoid this in a deck that
runs a lot of low-cost dorks, but despite my best
efforts I couldn’t manage to cram the necessary
amount of draw into the deck without incurring
a substantial cost to the beefiness of the deck.
On the opposite end of the ramp spectrum,
there’s the option of running a lot of high
cost ramp instead. This preserves topdeck quality
and lessens the number of cards needed to achieve
the same degree of ramp. However it will lead
to slower starts and fewer keepable hands,
worsening a deck’s mulligan phase and its ability
to get off the ground. But what if there was a
way to do the inverse of what was done in the
Goreclaw deck—to have the commander cover the
low-cost ramp, and then run a massive pile of
4-cost ramp? This is where Radha comes back
in as a two-drop mana dork that’s available at
all times. One potential Radha build could be to
run a lot of 4-5 cost plays, but these tend to
be a lot worse than 6-7 cost cards. Dropping a
generically high quality four drop on turn 3 such
as Forgotten Ancient or Atsushi is a lot less
impressive than dropping a Kogla or an Etali,
Primal Storm on turn 4, and creatures that are
six or more mana also tend to stay relevant
as topdecks, whereas 4-5 mana creatures are
by contrast often kinda disappointing to topdeck
later in the game. This is not to say that we’re
gonna be trying to let the deck get to the point
where what’s on top of its library is important,
but when you’re playing a cheap red-green
midrange deck, you gotta know that there
will be games where you don’t find enough of your
draw and end up relying on the heart of the cards.
And in those cases, you’ll usually be glad to
draw a Dragonlair Spider instead of an Arasta.
So this was my start in building Radha—4 cost
ramp that I can play on turn 3. There are some
different options here, including some really
potent mana dorks that might allow for an extra
explosive turn 4-5, but I made my decision
of what to put here largely with the intent
of hedging around a potential weakness for the
deck. See, green stompy decks tend to struggle
with one type of card above all others—board
wipes. And while mana dorks often allow for
faster acceleration than other types of ramp,
they have the downside that they generally get
eaten by board wipes alongside the big threats
that prompted the wipe. A big goal for this deck
was being able ramp relatively quickly into
6 and 7 drops, but also being able to play
through hate and keep scaling into the late
game. The ramp suite I ended up landing on
focused on a classic—Explosive Vegetation.
I run all 10 of these effects that exist,
as well as Blighted Woodland, an untapped land
that can also serve as turn 3 ramp if I activate
it during combat after attacking with Radha. From
there the deck ventures into a bunch of other
cards that perform some sort of ramp function,
including extra land spells like Mina and Denn,
filtering cards that produce treasures such as
Unexpected Windfall, and a handful of other cards.
Since I want some sort of ramp on turn 3 every
single game to allow me to play a six drop on
turn 4, I opted for 19 total cards that offer turn
3 ramp. That gives a 79% chance of drawing one in
each opening hand, a figure that is high enough to
leave some room for needing to mulligan for lands.
With my core idea for the deck consisting of
Radha and a pile of 4 cost ramp, I had a question
on my hands: how much low-cost stuff should I
run? I knew that it wouldn’t be a big amount,
and I eventually decided on literally none at
all, and this is for one key reason: cascade. A
big downside of cascade is how luck-based it
is. When you play a five cost cascade card,
it might hit a four cost card, but it also
might hit a one-cost card. However, if you
simply don’t run any cards that cost less than 4,
you’re guaranteed a pretty decent minimum level
of value from your cascade trigger. This fact
paired with my density of ramp on four means that
cascades and discovers are actually reasonably
predictable. Cascading for a four-or-less-cost
card yields an 85% chance of finding a card with
some sort of ramp attached, and cascading for
a five-or-less-cost card yields a two thirds
chance of finding specifically a ramp spell,
but an additional 14% chance of finding a card
that cascades for four, which I must remind you,
has a 85% chance of finding a ramp spell.
Cascading for a six-or-less-cost card has
a more modest 40% chance of finding a ramp
spell, but if we account for the cascade and
discover cards this ends up getting boosted up to
a 55% chance. What this silly jumble of numbers
means in practice is that the deck is effectively
running a high-20s number of ramp spells, and all
of them ramp for at least two mana or have other
upside. Translation: we’re in lands town, baby.
So what does the deck spend the resulting mana
on? As I alluded to earlier, a big place to
spend this mana is on 6-7 mana creatures, as
these work well both late and as a juicy turn
4 play. A lot of these are exactly what you’d
expect—Etali Primal Storm, Rampaging Baloths,
a decent handful of cascade creatures—but some
others are a bit further off the beaten track,
and this is motivated by a couple factors. For
one, I wanted to build this deck on a pretty
tight budget, both for the sake of my wallet and
to force me into some more creative directions,
so nothing over $4. Secondly, the deck
ramps very hard and has a very high curve,
and there are cards that work well with this.
One such card is Screamer Killer, a card from
the Warhammer 40k set that’s shockingly close to
being a Terror of the Peaks in my deck, but at a
tiny fraction of the price of that fancy dragon.
Another favorite of mine is Emergent Woodwurm,
a card that’s so underplayed and causes such a
large swing in board the turn it enters that I
frequently have opponents do a double take and ask
“wait, that card does what?” I also run Tyrant’s
Familiar and Thunderfoot Baloth. These are quite
powerful with a commander in play, but most decks
can’t take full advantage of them because
opponents can simply remove their commander
before attacks, which ends up being a soft two for
one. However, since my commander is a mana dork
that I don’t really care about past turn 4 or 5,
my opponents are far less eager to remove her, and
she’s pretty cheap to replay to get the lieutenant
ability back online if they do remove her.
A big theme among the rest of the Radha deck’s
high-cost creatures is something that it shares
with my Glissa deck—a decent portion of the
deck’s creatures have some sort of removal
attached. This is great, as it allows the deck to
pack a lot of ways to deal with opposing threats,
while also allowing the deck to put on
pressure by having a large density of
big creatures that it starts playing on turn
4. The deck also packs some amount of draw,
but far less than you’d expect. There are 7
engines and 2 one-time draw spells, and while
playing the first dozen or so games with the deck,
I’ve kept expecting to need to add more draw,
but it just hasn’t been necessary—the deck does
a perfectly fine job maintaining resources in
its hand. This once again goes back to the
mana curve—even though the deck gets massive
land counts, since roughly a third of the
deck is creatures that cost 5 or more mana,
it often stocks up a hand full of large threats
earlier in the game, giving it plenty of time to
find a draw engine as it builds up its land count.
This is supplemented by the cascade-Explosive
Vegetation plan, which thins the deck of lands
and to a lesser extent ramp spells, helping it
to draw into more big threats later. I’m broadly
not too impressed by the effect of deck thinning,
as a couple fewer lands won’t have a wildly
meaningful impact on a deck that is looking
to win by turn 8 or 9. Scale this up though,
and pulling 8 or more lands out of a deck
that is looking to grind way into the late game
does start to become decidedly more impactful.
The confluence of the Radha deck’s intense
density of ramp, vast number of high cost threats,
and adequate quantity of draw ends up being a
deck that stockpiles all game resources at the
same time—it develops its board while ramping
hard and maintaining plenty of resources in
hand. And this fact leads to the deck’s biggest
strength—its flexibility. Against faster decks
it can dig in its heels and focus on staying
alive until it has the resources to stabilize,
knowing it’ll easily outscale them later in the
game, whereas against decks that go bigger than
it in the late game it can advance a bunch of
large creatures and turn them sideways to get
that deck down to a manageable life total
before it gets scary. The deck also plays
through most hate just fine—it doesn’t
run significant numbers of artifacts,
enchantments, graveyard synergies, or pivotal
singular creatures. Board wipes are basically
the only commonly-played hate in EDH that causes
problems for a turbo-ramping big creature deck,
and the deck plays decently well through these,
too. Advancing a few threats is all that’s needed
to have a boardwipe-worthy board state, and
this generally leaves plenty of beefy stuff
in hand and far more lands than opponents
for purposes of playing them out. The deck’s
cascade creatures are also a thing that feels
perfectly fine to play into a board wipe, since
they usually find some sort of ramp that can help
the deck bounce back more quickly after the wipe.
Before I spend too much time indulgently hyping up
my deck, I should talk about the downsides of the
deck. For one, it lacks basically any instant
speed interaction—if I’m being generous it has
a grand total of four instant speed removal
cards and one instant speed protection card.
This is mostly a product of the deck being
a cascade deck that runs no cards below 4
mana—the desirable options for instant-speed
interaction are pretty slim. In addition,
the deck is extremely consistent in early turns,
an attribute that comes with both positives and
negatives. The positive is that as long as it
mulligans properly, the deck basically never
has do-nothing games. The downside is twofold—for
one, it can be a little boring, since the deck has
basically no meaningful decisions between the
mulligan phase and turn 4. The other issue is
that it’s predictable, since opponents who have
played against the deck know its rough curve out
of the first four turns. The fact that the deck
is locked into this curve-out is another reason
why I opted for the $50 budget—it literally
cannot increase the speed of its curve-outs,
so any deck that’s doing something substantially
more relevant on turn 4 than playing a 6 or 7 drop
beater is too far above the deck’s power level to
be worth trying to match. The deck also requires a
very aggressive mulligan policy to make sure
that it is able to get off the ground okay,
though at least it usually does fine starting
with 5 or 6 cards. All of these downsides are
pretty fundamentally tied to the deck’s core
construction—having a deck with no cards costing
less than 4 mana still curve out at a decent speed
requires making some concessions here and there.
At the end of the day, the process of building
this deck was the process of chasing a vibe.
It’s the vibe that I was chasing with my first
commander deck, it’s the vibe I was chasing with
when I made Glissacruiser, and it’s a vibe that
I’ll hopefully call it quits with chasing now that
I have this Radha deck. This vibe of having all of
the resources, of being the big bad at the table,
of playing midrange to the bleeding edge of
what that term can possibly mean—I just find
it super fun, and I think it makes for a cool
table dynamic as long as the deck in question
has enough interaction. To me, building a deck
that satisfies a particular feeling is one of
the best parts of casual commander, especially
if the resulting deck ends up being strange and
unique. The challenge of making a deck that is
conceptually cool, enjoyable to play, and good
for table dynamics is a fun one to navigate, and
when it works out the results can be really great.
That’s all for this video, thanks for
watching! I’ll be posting an endnote
to my Patreon tomorrow where I discuss some
of the weirder card choices in the deck that
didn’t make it into the video. That’s right,
I didn’t even talk about the caves package.
I’m also currently taking submissions for a
bonus video later this month where I give my
thoughts on three patron decks, so if you want
a chance of having your deck reviewed by me,
you can sign up for my Patreon and
submit your deck within the next week.